foreign
[Music]
some new footage from the Mandalorian
season three let's get straight into the
breakdown so the trailer begins with
grief kaga saying so I heard you all
back to Mando I heard you were back I
gotta say grief has really dripped
up here since I'm really enjoying the
new fashion he has in this season we can
also see this little interesting
creature next to groofkaga and honestly
I got no clue what in the hell this
thing is let me know what you guys think
in the comment section below we then
have an extended shot from baby Yoda in
the cave sequence so it's after he has
just force pushed this creature back we
see a new shot of him here so it looks
like baby Yoda is going to utilize his
force abilities more in this season so
I'm excited to see that and I'm also
excited to see his Force powers develop
even more across this season we have
even more baby Yoda cuteness here then
we have a little bit more footage of a
really big Mandalore in fighting
sequence like just in this Frame alone
you can see so many different types of
mandalorians they even seem to be some
kid mandalorians running around we then
have a new shot of Bo Katan and I gotta
say we've actually seen a lot of footage
of Bo Katan in the marketing for the
mandalorians it seems like she's going
to play a big role in the season which
is a very very exciting we then actually
have a shot of someone who seems to be
Dr Pershing so it seems like he's going
to play a part in this season and I'm
excited to see what part he'll play in
this story and then to end off this
trailer we have some new footage of the
dogfighting sequence and then the last
shot is of Mando and baby Yoda in the
cockpit together again more baby Yoda
cuteness and I keep calling him baby
Yoda but it's just I don't know it's
just a habit at this point I know he's
grogu but it's just hard to break the
habit but that is about everything for
this new trailers let me know what you
guys think about this trailer in the
comment section below and are you
excited for the Mandalorian season 3 and
also if you haven't already please do
consider subscribing and liking the
video to show your support thanks for
watching